hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review
it's uh back to school time again this
time on a topic that may sound trivial
but it actually has fair amount of
complexity underneath uh luckily
you can't learn it uh it's just
something that's not usually talked
about
online and that is frequency response
measurements
um you know you all probably know have
heard of the term
and probably have some idea of what it
means the curves typically look like
this
this recent jbl 4349
studio monitor that i tested and
it always has two axes one is the
frequency
the frequency response and the vertical
scale varies depending
depending on what we're showing in this
case is the spl or sound pressure that
the speaker is producing if we're
measuring a dac
or amplifier that'll be the output
voltage typically but
it really doesn't matter what this is as
long as you know we understand more or
less this is the output and this is the
frequency and
and we look at how that output varies
now in case of amplifiers and things the
frequency responds often
extremely smooth and flat and then he
rolls off at some point
and we can judge that easily you don't
need to watch this video to learn that
but check out this frequency response
we have a little dip in here oops sorry
you can't see my mouse
uh there's a little dip in here there's
a little peak in here
then more or less is okay but we got
these little tiny wiggles then we have a
little valley in here then it goes up a
little bit then we have a broad area
that's
up here then we have some more wiggles
um
a lot of people who really you know die
hard objectivists say well this is all i
need and i can tell you something sounds
well my question is what's you know what
does this sound like
if it you know if you have two little
shoulders like this versus one
does it make a difference what if it's
this wide
what if it's less than this peak but
broad
what difference does that make so and
that's the topic that i'm going to cover
in this video
um on this which is how do we interpret
a frequency response measurement from a
speaker and headphone
where it's never straightforward just
like the arrow that i've
drawn and so you need to have some skill
in interpreting that
um so just let's bring up a headphone
for example
this is a hi-fi man sundara that i
recently reviewed
we look at the frequency response this
part's easy you say well okay there's
less bass way down here but what about
this little wiggle over here is that
audible
but this will go over here um then we
have this broad region which is just a
little bit below a target horrible is
that versus these
then we have these peaks in here how
horrible are they
this this valley in here this seems very
very large deviation correct
so this must surely be a lot more
audible than
something like this or maybe even this
right like this area seems very minor
compared to this massive
20 25 db changes in frequency response
so
clearly we need to have some tools to
understand this
i can guarantee you that if you use your
lay intuition it would be wrong
uh on this thing so to understand
how we analyze these things we have to
look at psychoacoustics psychoacoustics
is a research of
human hearing and tons of tons of
studies to be done in
last 80 years or so on
you know how do we perceive sound uh
millions of tests with respect to
frequency tonality
sounds going up and down what have you
and this is done both for medical
purposes and also for
pleasure as far as you know music
enjoyment and so forth
the key concept i want you to understand
in here which is a gnarly one for any
lay person to understand but
stay with me and it's called the
auditory filter bandwidth
and it's measured in in what we call erb
equivalent rectangular bandwidth our
hearing system
has a what we call a filter bank a set
of uh
resonators that as the sound uh agitates
those
points you know we pick up basically
amplifies that that
that region and we hear it and the
shapes of those auditory
filters is actually not pretty it
changes with frequency
and it has a complex shape but what is
important is that within that
auditory filter bank's bandwidth
if you have a bunch of sounds tones that
are close together they
essentially get averaged by the year the
ear can't distinguish between them when
they're within one filter bank
so imagine if i tell you numbers 1 to
100
but you can only have 10 10 buckets in
there 1 to 10
and then to 20 and and so forth so
within those buckets variations are not
as important the ear basically averages
all the spectrum energy in that filter
bank
now i warned you this would be complex
but um
one simplification we have is which is
called the
this erb thing and you can go to
wikipedia unfortunately this page
doesn't have any uh
um graphs in here and and i should have
probably brought one up but
we can simplify the uh the auditory
filters as being rectangular as if you
just go up like a
you know pulse and we say if the filter
was
rectangular how wide is it
and the width of that filter bank
in your hearing system widens as
frequencies go up
what does it mean to widen that means
you have less discrimination
which means that more tones are
averaged together and that's how you
hear them so
if one frequency is higher and one
frequency is lower they get added up
to each other and average out as a total
energy
the way that as i just explained there's
a formula in this uh wikipedia that
actually tells you you can
grossly simplify this but it's very
useful for this kind of
analysis that we want to do back in my
envelope analysis and you can see in
here basically just depends on the
frequency
and you plot that you get a graph that
looks like this
basically this is 20 hertz at the bottom
sorry it's a small graph
and it says that at 20 hertz our
auditory bandwidth is only 25 hertz to
30 hertz
so that means very little very few
frequencies
are averaged that means in the context
of a speaker in a room
where the room activates magnifies
certain frequencies we actually care
about a very narrow analysis of of those
frequencies
but look at what happens at 20 000 hertz
at 20 000 hertz
this thing shoots up to like 3 000 hertz
so a tone that's mulch of tones that are
at 20 000 hertz they all get averaged
within a three kilohertz bandwidth
um so what this means is that as you go
left to right in your frequency response
so from here on variations here
are far more audible because the hearing
bandwidth this erb is very narrow which
means very frequent
very few frequencies are added together
to build the total
energy that your hearing system is going
to perceive
whereas when you get up here you can see
these little wiggles
your erb is wider it's a big chunk over
here it's this wide so it will average
out these things so these little peaks
and the valleys
on the right are never heard whereas the
same peaks and the valleys
here are audible so indeed this can be
audible
although you know the level is so low
here that personally
you know wouldn't bother with one or two
db corrections but if this was a little
louder for sure
it's something that that would be
audible um
and you can see the width of this guy is
the same as with these things but
perceptually they're not at all the same
so let's take this example further and
this is an article by the way that i
wrote
um for white screen review magazine a
few years ago and i'll put a link in the
description
where it talks about this detail this
has a lot of
applications both in just simple
frequency response measurements but also
in
in measuring your room and acoustics in
your room and if you don't understand
this you can really chase your tail
uh strongly so this is a
actually a measurement of a speaker i
have in a room
and at high resolution basically no
filtering
and look at what the frequency response
in room looks like
if you've never done this is like whoa
what is this
no way is this the frequency response
are we really hearing all this
wildness well obviously we're not
hearing this wireless and it's because
of erb
but uh truly this is what you get
why do you get this because direct sound
comes to the microphone in here but so
does all the reflections from
every surface since they all have
different delays they're out of phase
with each other and they mix up and
essentially make this
random waveform that you see in here
every time a waveform gets delayed
enough to be out of phase it will
actually
cancel resulting in these sharp drops
and if it's the other way around it will
actually add so
it's a complex thing now a microphone is
we say it's a dumb thing microphone has
no psychoacoustics analysis and
neither does a simple measurement like
this but your brain
and your hearing system does not hear
this how does it hear it
you need to go and smooth that smoothing
means filtering this the ups and downs
equivalent to what your hearing system
perceives so if i'm interested in
knowing what's happening in high
frequencies this one-third octave
filtering
will give me that but in low frequencies
now it's lying to me it smoothed out all
this stuff saying there are no ups and
downs well that's false because there
are clearly
ups and downs in here and one third of
an octave is way way too wide
to show that so what you really want to
have is an adaptive filtering
where you filter very little at low
frequencies and you filter a lot at high
frequencies
to get an idea of what is your room
sound
if you will um an example of applying
this
uh is when i reviewed the odyssey room
eq
and uh here i'm measuring my own
reversal onto
speakers and it's sort of a before and
after correction that's
performed you can see how messy this
this graph is
right this high resolution again but
here
all these little peaks actually mean
something because they are audible the
bandwidth in here is well more than
10 or 20 hertz and here you want to get
a filter correct if it's at 14
no 14. if it's at 35 hertz you want to
put a filter at 35 hertz you want to
find this exact peak in here
and put a 35 hertz and then you want to
adjust the width of the filter to be
only this wide you don't want to go past
in here because then it'll
change this area so in low frequencies
up to about 100 200 hertz
all of these things are real and the
peaks and valleys here
when you get up here this is all garbage
because this is not what you hear
low frequencies what you see is what you
get high frequency
what you see is not what you hear
and uh so to to see
what we perceive as just overall
tonality forgetting about as much about
the
ups and downs i went ahead did the
one-third octave
filtering and then all room equalization
systems have uh
what is called a target response curve
and this is the preferred one
with odyssey you have to go then
anamorans have an app where to let you
edit that and that's what you want to
have this this stock one
doesn't have this and and screws things
up but anyway it wants to achieve this
line but this line this target has no
ups and downs right so it is
as filters and as smooth as possible so
we
we got to get take our frequency respond
also
and smooth it out also so we can see
where we stand relative
to this target now by the way this
microphone i use is a crummy mark uh it
was the market i think came with avr or
something and i don't have the
calibration for it so
you know it droops down here ignore that
but here we can see that we're more or
less
tracking this target but in here we had
a big deviation
and obviously went ahead and and
corrected that
uh in here and then excuse me you try to
follow this curve until
you know we lost the calibration on this
thing
so it's very important to uh
pay attention to you know the filtering
that you use and this is a feature this
is roomy cube wizard
that lets you go in there and and filter
the response
on this thing now let's go back to the
original 43 949
speaker that i reviewed and i might do a
standalone video on this
uh the biggest flaw in here was that it
actually two flaws one was that there's
a dip in here the crossover
and then there's also the twitter level
is elevated
up here fortunately it has some dip
switches which i'm showing down here
where you can take this and knock it
down and this would be quite audible
because it goes from 2 kilohertz all the
way up to
maximum frequency of 10 kilos plus all
of it is
elevated it's the classic thing of
thinking that more highs
sell speakers better and and they do so
even though it's less accurate
um yeah they're in there so but
a lot of people were horrified of of
this dip and i was upset at it too
because harmon tends to
parent company jbl it knows that this
has to be flat for the best sound
so i went ahead and listened to it and i
dialed in an
eq in there
and that's the equalization that i put
in verse of that it seems like a very
large correction in here right it's a 4
db and
at 1500 hertz so this that's a lot of
boosting in here
but i tell you the effects are quite
subtle it is not
at all night and day turning and turn it
on and say wow
listen up now it was very subtle it was
a good change
needed to have that eq in there um but
it's very subtle
so here's an example of the eye
deceiving us and why is the eye
deceiving us because
the erb here is not
this narrow in here is you're probably
getting the filter banks are averaging
fair bit
let me go back to the original graph
averaging these fair bits so
clearly we're not hearing a big valley
in here where we're hearing
chunks of it averaging here in chunks
with average here
and so it's important to listen um
a lot of people are shocked when i say
when it comes to uh
room eq and room sound reproduction
your ears are you must use your ears and
because your ears
and your brain work together to tell you
what you perceive
and you know single graph
measurements can be quite misleading so
you got to have the skill to either
apply
psychoacoustics manually like i've been
teaching you right now in this video
or go ahead and experiment with
equalization so
take your current system bring up a
parametric eq it has to be a parametric
eq
why because it has this q value at the
bottom that i've set to 2.5 and when you
set that q value that changes the
how wide the filter is how many
frequencies it impacts
go ahead and take the same filter
and put it up at 10 kilohertz or eight
kilohertz
and vary its shape you'll notice that if
you make it quite
narrow where q is five or six
you'll turn it on and off it'll actually
make no difference you can make it like
six or eight db
peaks or dips and you can turn it on and
off
you know it'll be very subtle to no
difference at all
why because again you're hearing filter
bank
at high frequencies is very broad very
lazy
and therefore if you make a correction
in the middle of it the little sliver in
that
it doesn't change the total energy much
and if it doesn't change the total
energy much
it's not an audible thing so for that
reason
i i see a lot of people going out there
and taking
making headphone measurements like this
and they come up with tons and tons of
filters
when i do my equalizations you see very
few filters
even like this one in here i put in here
was very subtle
on this thing because again it's it's
quite narrow in here
um i sometimes go ahead and experiment
by putting some other corrections in
here
but there are differences next to zero
people
who use a computer program generate
these filters
the computer program just takes this uh
frequency response here and attempts to
flatten all of these things it will
flatten this little thing in here
and flatten this it'll flatten this
it'll flatten that and all of a sudden
you have
18 filters in there but if you go in
there and turn those filters on and off
you'll notice that many of them will not
make a difference i
like this little thing in here two or
three db
bandwidth is like 300 hertz this is just
not audible in the way it seems the
other thing is that these filters don't
act in the way you think
they're they're shown in pretty graphs
like i have in here that this is what
they think they're gonna do
but usually they have some spillover
effects and the actual response isn't
precisely this
so that's another reason to not do that
um
recently i was watching somebody's video
on on headphone tuning and
uh uh this little nine dollar sony
headphone i'd reviewed and i said bad eq
it makes sound good
and i just put a few filters in there he
said it sounded terrible with those
filters but then he went and said
i created my own without measurements
and he wound up with 30 filters in there
my 30 filters there's no way with 30
filters you can have anything that's
that's resembling what cycle acoustics
tells you
of course it's very easy to imagine that
it makes a change by the way
you can put a filter on there and think
that you're reducing the highs and
your brain may say reducing the highs so
a lot of times there's this on
off switch you can see here i'll close
my eyes and i'll turn it on and off
randomly where i don't know what state
is in
then i'll switch it back and forth to
make sure that i'm not
fooling myself into thinking that uh the
filter is making an effect or not
and in fact if if the effect is not
large i'll leave it out
and i'll just show you the major ones
and uh usually if a product requires
more than four or five of these filters
i i give up anyway it just
means the designer didn't do a good
enough job in
in you know fixing all the flaws i don't
mind fixing one or two things or
with my preference in here having more
bass boost but not
me becoming a designer on that thing
so bottom line is just be careful in
looking at frequency response
measurements
uh always in your mind have a little uh
psychoacoustic simulator that says ah
these are audible like this little peak
in here
likely is audible and then in this case
it was a good thing
but it also gets combined with room
modes so that's another topic we'll
talk about in the future so this
interpreting the low frequencies
in a loudspeaker is got its own
complexities beyond what i talked about
but the foundation is
what i said the changes in frequency
response
earlier matter more than later in
frequencies
and how wide they are makes a bigger
difference in audibility
than the narrow ones so these little
wiggles in here
are just not audible because they you
have to get lucky for a musical note to
just hit that
right there for it to be half a d louder
and with music having many tones you're
just not gonna hear that well something
broad like this
yeah there's more chances of musical
notes hitting that so
this this obviously is is audible
okay so hopefully you learned something
uh
and if you already knew all these things
then great
a number of people on the forum on asr
forum know these things
uh but i imagine most people haven't
been exposed to the full theory from
start to finish
and i thought i'd do this video
see you in a future video bye